rustle I have to ask you are you still
wearing the tight leather trousers
because you wore them very well and I
say that in it with great respect but no
one rocked leather trousers like you but
now I see you almost in this mother
teresa mode do you still break out their
trousers every now and then I became
vegan some time ago due to the nagging
the constant cultural nagging to become
vegan and so like I do have tight
uncomfortable age-inappropriate leg wear
but I can slip on if I'm required to
perform lives but they're not leather
anymore and look do what is the myth of
the wild man who is the wild man the
wild man is a figure that we need to
maintain in culture because we know in
our hearts that civilization is
temporary or show the Great Sage and
some would say crackpot said what is
civilization but a clearing in the
forest and now isn't it becoming evident
clear that all of our constructs all of
our concepts all of our systems our
civilization is crumbling around us what
then if you have no access to the wild
man what then if you can't call upon a
bearded gentleman in pleather trousers
to thrust you forward into a
revolutionary new era what then I ask
you Conan ok
Russell while you were ranting I called
the police and the matter they're going
to break down break down your door in
about two minutes just go with them and
when they give you a pill take it and
you'll have a nice sleep ok the British
Constabulary would have more respect to
arrest an Englishman in his own home his
own blanket certainly the best of you an
Irish descended living monument to
paganism
now I'm told that are we limited
somewhat by the life of your battery of
your computer is that right
your battery is running low is that
correct no the reason I'm the only
limitation is you know the limitations
have already been placed upon us in fact
that this phone is plugged into the wall
which prohibits my motion more than I
would like but to be honest Coenen what
would I do would I be pure letting
around the room I mean what would one do
what would one do this is I like you
this way if you're very christ-like
thank you you are a Buddha you represent
in this mode right now perennialism
Aldous Huxley called that recognizing
the underlying archetypal connections
that unify all theology and and
religious faiths guess what you're on
American television
you have to dumb it down television I
remember